all right we just go to we just got to
talk about something real quick so one
of the biggest announcements at Google's
fall event that they just had was that
they're planning on supporting the pixel
8 and pixel 8 Pro with 7 years of os
security and feature drop Updates this
is industry-leading and super awesome
here's a list of some of the other
promises that have been made in the
smartphone world for how long down the
road they plan on supporting their
devices in the world of Android this is
unprecedented so clearly this was one of
the best announcements of the entire
Google event and we are finally happy to
see that but on the other hand Google
has a rich history of discontinuing
products and abandoning projects and
services that have a lot of people using
them or depending on them so how do we
Square those two things like you would
think that relying on a big company is
better than relying on a small one as
far as like supporting projects down the
road like if I was going to set up a new
smart home for example I wouldn't want
to set up one with like a tiny startup
that I don't know if they're going to
exist in 5 years cuz then all my smart
home stuff might not work when that
company goes out of business so you'd
think a bigger more established company
would be more reliable but it turns out
the same problem can happen when you
rely on a gigantic company like Google
because something you might get invested
in or start using might just be like a
small rounding error for them that they
might just get rid of at any time so I
think the thing that really summarizes
this all well is I have a friend that
says that Google is super willing to
spin up new projects and be aggressive
and Inn all the time but if that new
project doesn't either get a billion
users or make a billion dollars then it
is liable to get AED at any time so
that's why literally just in the past
few weeks we have seen Google domains
Google Jam board Google podcasts and
pixel pass all killed all active
services with various amounts of users
just destroyed just killed and the
further back you go the more there are
like this it feels like a running joke
that Google will announce and kill a new
messaging service every year but
just keep scrolling back like there's
entire web pages dedicated to
chronicling the long list of things that
Google has killed remember Google+
remember the inbox app Remember Hangouts
remember aloe remember chomecast audio
stadia the list goes on now when they
kill these products or Services there
are often various degrees to which
they're able to replace them or support
everyone that they just rug pulled so
like something like Google play music
okay they were launching another service
called YouTube music and it had a lot of
congruent features so they didn't have
the need to have both so they made it
easy to Port your entire library from
one to the other you still be missing
some features but at least you still
have your whole Library so that was nice
there's a similar thing with Google
podcasts like it was a pretty solid
podcast app but they again wanted to
bring those things into YouTube music so
they've worked on an import process and
some tutorials for that and like it's a
good effort it's good to at least try to
do that sort of thing but it's not
always perfect Google Jam board you
might not have heard of Google Jam board
but weirdly enough the pro Ultimate
Frisbee team I've played on New York
Empire uses Google Jam board for like
our scouting documents for like writing
everything down and players and tencies
and all that sort of thing and it's gone
now or at least by the end of the year
it'll be gone so I guess we'll just find
something else to use Google stadia the
gaming service only lasted a couple of
years the only saving grace with this
one is when it got asked they would at
least let you export your save data so
you could use it on another platform and
then they refunded every stadia user for
every game but again there are no
Alternatives fun fact and this is this's
a true story I had literally just
switched MKBHD dcom from Squarespace to
Google domains it was like a big domain
transfer process that took like 24 hours
and I was like nervous to do it but I
finally did it and then within a week
Google killed Google domains and sold
all of those domains back to
Squarespace so there are no Google
domains anymore but maybe the craziest
recent one would be pixel pass pixel
pass is crazy so if you haven't heard of
it it was basically a subscription plan
that was launched alongside the pixel 6
and the idea was you sign up and then
you pay 45 bucks a month you get the
brand new phone and then you get YouTube
premium YouTube music a bunch of Google
one storage and some other stuff all
included packaged together and then you
get a new pixel for free every 2 years
which I mean sounds pretty sweet right
if you use a bunch of Google services
they're all packaged together the
overall price would be a little bit
lower than if you'd bought all of these
things individually and then who
wouldn't want to upgrade to a new pixel
phone roughly once every 2 years sounds
pretty sweet a bunch of people signed up
and then exactly 22 months after they
announced it so a month and a half
before the first upgrade cycle they
quietly killed the program and nobody
got their free phone upgrade because
they killed it right before they were
supposed to and there have been no
announced Alternatives the list goes on
and on and on but clearly this type of
behavior erods your trust in anything
Google me personally I was thinking
about maybe switching to Google F
there's a bunch of other carriers out
there I was going to maybe try it the
integration with the pixel seems cool
but I cannot be sure that it'll still
exist in a year or two so I'm not going
to do it so my point is launching
ambitious new things which is what
Google does is easy supporting those
ambitious new things for a long time is
hard and this new announcement of seven
years of software updates for the pixel
is the most ambitious
software support plan we've ever seen in
the smartphone world and that's what
makes it so awesome and so hard to
believe at the same time like if I was
at Google honestly watching this I would
really want to make this promise come
true I think it's a great promise
clearly I hope more companies see
Google's announcement and try to follow
and do the same thing because making
people's devices more useful and more
secure for a longer time is a win for
everyone for the users for security for
the environment if people use their
phones longer so like if this pans out
the phones people are buying today will
be up to date till 2030 which is an
eternity in the tech world that is so
sick so I want to give them credit for
an awesome promise but it's a promise
and Google breaks promises all the time
that's that's where we're at right now I
want it to be real but but we'll see
will the pixel even be around in s years
we we don't know the Nexus program only
lasted 5 years before they killed that
and then started pixel stuff and we are
on year8 of the pixel now will it last
seven more years I don't even know but
then actually this also ties into
another bit of a mini Trend we've
observed lately that I wanted to talk
about which is new announcements from
tech companies that have features that
are coming soon and this isn't just
Google this has happened across the
board but this has happened where a
device will come out but then the new
features aren't available at launch so
reviewers aren't even able to test the
new features until well after the thing
is in the wild you know Google just did
this with the pixel the video boost
feature they talked about on stage that
they said is coming later uh video night
site is also not available at launch
that's coming later but like I said not
just Google Apple's done this actually
many times with iPhone camera features
and they've done it again this year with
a bunch of stuff the journal app on the
iPhone is still not there coming later
this year uh the airdrop transfer via
the Internet feature is also not in the
phones yet that's still coming later
this year
and the double tap feature for the Apple
watch which is one of the biggest new
features of the entire watch was
announced on stage but it's still in
beta a month later and coming soon I've
just noticed a bunch of these over the
past couple months it kind of feels like
I tweeted about this it kind of feels
like the gaming
industry precedent where a lot of gaming
Studios will release like a half
finished game kind of to just get it out
there and maybe test the waters and if
it hooks then maybe they'll throw a
bunch of Patches at it and updates at it
but releasing half finished games is is
just not great so I definitely don't
love this trend for for Tech and for
smartphones and Hardware um but for
slightly different reasons one just
because it makes them much harder to
review if the new feature is not out and
we can't test it and then we review
what's out but then a big new feature
comes later tough but I guess I'll just
stick with the thing that I've said from
the beginning which is never buy a new
piece of tech based on the promise of
future software updates just don't do it
just buy it for what it is today and if
there's stuff coming later and it
actually gets delivered on the promise
some are better at delivering that than
others then it's a bonus it just it's an
extra value ad for the thing that you
are already happy with but never buy it
just based on the promise of future
updates so that's it I just had some
thoughts I wanted to get out into the
world hopefully Google and apple and
others are listening hopefully they're
able to deliver on these promises but
also hopefully they're able to deliver
on things that they promised
at launch when they can and we'll keep
an eye on Pixel I'm testing the phones
I'll be reviewing them subscribe to see
the review when it comes out that's it
for now thanks for watching catch you in
the next one
[Music]
peace